[Music]
foreign
review the show where we break down a
year to bring you some of the most
notable moments in TV and film month by
month we're heading back to 1977 a year
that included a Freaky Friday a Saturday
Night Fever and a close encounter of the
Third Kind not to mention an
oscar-winning performance from Diane
Keaton in the best picture winning Annie
Hall and there was a certain space
Western that went from just a movie to a
cultural phenomenon at light speed Star
Wars I'm talking about Star Wars plus
the world of Television said goodbye to
the Mary Tyler Moore Show and hello to
new shows like chips and Three's Company
so come and knock on my door because
here's your year in review 1977 Edition
[Music]
I wish I could switch places with her
for just one day
[Music]
thank you
arriving in wide release in January on a
Friday by the way was the original
cinematic version of the family comedy
Freaky Friday the film is based on the
1972 novel of the same name by Mary
Rogers who also wrote the screenplay and
it follows a mother and daughter played
by Barbara Harris and a young Jody
Foster who get a taste of each other's
lives after they somehow switch bodies
Freaky Friday performed well at the box
office pulling in 36 million dollars on
a 5 million dollar budget and picked up
three Golden Globe nominations including
one each for both Barbara Harris and
Jody Foster I wish I had my own body
back
[Music]
don't ask me
don't ask me could you do it again I
hope not and there have been three
remakes thus far including a made-for-tv
movie in 1995 starring Shelley Long and
Gabby Hoffman and another theatrical
release in 2003 with Jamie Lee Curtis
and Lindsay Lohan as mother and daughter
but there can only be one original
critics say Freaky Friday is too well
behaved to live up to its comedic
potential but sprightly turns by Barbara
Harris and Jody Foster give the body
swapping farsum charm
[Music]
you know what I I think Beth would want
to come home if you just show her that
you miss her why don't you come right
off and say it Mary you'd think I'm a
lousy mother
no I don't feel as I'll tell you exactly
what I think
I think
I what are you trying to say I'm trying
to think of a nice way to say that I
think you're a lousy mother
March 19th of 1977 marked a sad day in
television when the final episode of The
Mary Tyler Moore Show aired on CBS
titled the last show it was the 168th
episode and the end of a seven season
run the final scene included now iconic
images of the main characters huddled
together and not letting go along with
Mary eventually turning out the lights
and closing the door
thank you for being my family
now for the hard part
how do we leave this room
the episode 1 and Emmy Award for
outstanding writing in a comedy series
although it ranked just sixth in the
ratings during the week of its initial
broadcast but it clearly went on to have
an impact including on Friends
co-creator Marta Kaufman who called this
finale the gold standard and said that
it influenced the final episode of her
iconic sitcom Friends critics say an
exceptional Ensemble and a smart sense
of humor suggests that the Mary Tyler
Moore Show and its titular star may just
make it after all
[Music]
thank you
there is any other way out
forever
did you have a plan for getting out
this was the first installment in the
Star Wars franchise but the fourth
episode in the nine part Skywalker Saga
you get that right the film follows Luke
Skywalker Han Solo Chewbacca and a
couple pretty famous droids as they try
to rescue Princess Leia from the evil
Darth Vader and help the Rebel Alliance
restore freedom to the Galaxy the film
ended up surpassing Jaws as the highest
grossing film ever until E.T took it
over in 1982 and Star Wars has since
evolved into the fifth highest grossing
media franchise of all time not bad
considering George Lucas left town
opening weekend fearing the worst
heading to Hawaii with Steven Spielberg
where they came up with the idea for the
first Indiana Jones film I didn't write
a movie on my vacation to Hawaii don't
try to fragrance with your sorcerer's
ways Lord Vader your sad Devotion to
that ancient religion has not helped you
conjure up the stolen data tapes or
giving you Clairvoyance enough to find
the rebels hidden fort
I find your lack of faith disturbing
enough of this later release him
Star Wars which has been retroactively
retitled episode 4 A New Hope had a 20th
anniversary theatrical reissue in 1997
that included changes like the computer
modified effects altered dialogue
re-edited shots and added scenes and
with multiple new series popping up on
Disney plus involving many of the same
characters and settings the film's
Legacy has yet to be totally mapped out
critics say a legendarily expansive and
ambitious start to the Sci-Fi Saga
George Lucas opened our eyes to the
possibilities of Blockbuster filmmaking
and things have never been the same
that's not good
[Music]
and that's worse
drop me off here I'll catch a cab
too late now
Reynolds Stars alongside Jerry Reed
named Bandit and snowman respectively as
two Bootleggers attempting to illegally
move 400 cases of cores from Texarkana
to Atlanta the film also Stars Jackie
Gleason as a sheriff who's after them
and Sally Field as an unlikely passenger
and banned its car it took a while for
this movie to catch on with Studios and
producers in part because it was the
directorial debut for Hal Needham who
had only worked as a stuntman in
Hollywood to that point
wait a minute scratch that hold it
I can't lie to you chef
you're too good a man look over your
left shoulder
[Music]
we're on our way to Boston to get some
clam chops
[Music]
but once Needham's friend Burt Reynolds
agreed to start things changed and
Smokey and the Bandit went on to become
the second highest grossing film of the
Year behind Star Wars earning 126
million dollars on a 4 million dollar
budget I guess you could say they made
off like Bandits who's writing these
Scripts
I need a name critics say not much in
the head but plenty beneath the hood
Smokey and the Bandit is infectious fun
with plenty of car wrecks to keep the
eyes glued
we're carrying three cases each
one is enough to blow your fire six
cases will blow out the whole field
that means you don't think all the
trucks will make one of us is a bag of
it we won dollar a legal residence
oh we don't die
you live in four hours
and from transporting beer to
transporting nitroglycerin the film's
sorcerer opened in June directed and
co-produced by William friedkin from The
French Connection and Exorcist Fame the
budget for sorcerer ended up ballooning
to around 22 million dollars and it was
only able to bring home 9 million at the
box office many attribute the low
numbers to the fact that it was
competing with Star Wars already a
cultural phenomenon at that point just a
month later
foreign
[Music]
side although I don't know how many
millions this is worth after receiving
negative reviews initially this movie
has since been re-evaluated by critics
with many considering it a forgotten gem
yeah maybe that's not worth that many
millions but but critics say sorcerer
which obstinately Motors Along on its
unpredictable speed features ambitious
sequences of insane White Knuckle
tension
[Music]
they lied to us
[Applause]
[Music]
she's here
foreign
[Applause]
and making its way to America in August
of 1977 was the Italian supernatural
horror film Suspiria directed and
co-written by Dario Argento this one
Stars Jessica Harper as an American
dancer named Susie who shows up to a
prestigious German Ballet Academy and
begins to uncover its terrifying secret
history 20th Century Fox had the
American distribution rights for the
film but they were reluctant to release
it because of the violent content sure
enough Suspiria ended up being Fox's
seventh highest grossing film of the
year and argento's highest grossing film
in the U.S you wanted to kill Elena
Marcus
hell is behind that door
you look like you need that now
the Living Dead
[Music]
and the film is actually the first part
of what's known as argento's three
mothers Trilogy which also includes
1980s Inferno and 2007's mother of tears
but Suspiria has been the most well
received critics say the blood pours
freely in argento's classic Suspiria a
giello horror as grandiose and glossy as
it is Gory
foreign
hitting theaters at the end of August
was the British historical drama the
Duelists which marked the feature
directorial debut of some guy named
Ridley Scott who had just done TV
commercials to that point and backing
him was a cast that included Harvey
Keitel Keith Carradine and Albert Finney
the film begins in France at the
beginning of the 1800s where a
mild-mannered lieutenant is forced into
a duel with a temperamental and a
rational Lieutenant over a minor
perceived slight
oh
foreign
leads to many more duels over the next
several years the Duelists which is
based on a short story by Joseph Conrad
won the Best debut film award at 1977's
canned film festival and it kick-started
a decorated film career for Scott that
has included multiple Oscar nominations
plus Emmy and bafta wins critics say
Rich stylized visuals work with
effective performances and really
Scott's take on Joseph Conrad's
Napoleonic story resulting in an
impressive feature film debut for the
director
whoa
hey punch forget it
that really kills my day you know
there's no justice in life John only
luck well if that's the case you got to
be the luckiest guy in the world because
that statue fall back at the floor level
you almost closed the book it's done
it was beautiful come on admit it that
fast itself that real tight 360 lock to
lock
complete and total control
from the highways of California and
straight into living rooms everywhere on
September 15th was the crime drama
series chips airing for six seasons and
139 episodes on NBC plus one reunion TV
film in 1998. this show starred Erik
Estrada and Larry Wilcox as two
motorcycle officers on the California
Highway Patrol solving crimes and
helping in trouble
[Music]
you're almost there
much of the series was filmed around
recently completed but not yet open to
the public sections of Los Angeles
freeways and each episode was usually a
combination of light comedy and drama
and usually managed to highlight the
SoCal social lives of the series's main
stars critics say the lack of violence
is refreshing and Eric Estrada proves
himself Adept at slapstick Shenanigans
but more often not chips is about as
entertaining as being stuck in Los
Angeles traffic
[Music]
foreign
making contact with humans in November
of 1977 was Close Encounters of the
Third Kind written and directed by
Steven Spielberg who was coming off the
very successful Jaws a couple years
prior the film stars Richard Dreyfus who
was also coming off jaws and actually
heard Spielberg discussing this film on
the set of that film and campaigned for
the part he plays a blue color every man
in Indiana whose life changes after an
encounter with a UFO at one point
Spielberg was considering that this was
more of a documentary or even low budget
feature about people who believe in UFOs
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
foreign
but It ultimately evolved into something
much bigger getting made for just under
20 million dollars and going on to
grossing over 300 million dollars
worldwide because of that and because
they rushed him to finish it in 1977
instead of his desired summer of 78
release date Columbia Pictures gave
Spielberg more money to go back in and
add some things for a special edition
director's cut of the film released in
1980. this also set of director's cut
Trend that has continued for decades
critics say Close Encounters of the
Third Kind is a deeply Humane sci-fi
exploring male Obsession Cosmic
mysticism and music
[Music]
it's not necessary I'll tell you what I
do
open a paint store I got raised this
week right you work in a paste all right
you probably live with your family you
hang out with your buddies and on
Saturday night you go you blow it all
off 2001 right that's right
we are cliche in nowhere
and you waited no place
what do you gotta Stairway To the Stars
or what yeah maybe holiday gift list no
doubt included bell bottoms disco music
and dance lessons after the music and
dance filled drama Saturday Night Fever
hit theaters in December the film stars
John Travolta as Tony Monero a 19 year
old who lives at home and works at a
paint store during the week while living
it up at disco clubs on the weekends and
this not only moved John Travolta from
TV star to movie star it helped bring
disco music into the mainstream all
around the globe along with the music
Saturday Night Fever shined a light on
the subculture surrounding the Disco ERA
with things like the fashion the
promiscuity and the Glorious
choreography everybody's got a dump on
somebody right of course I mean
everybody everybody can't do a straight
right my pod goes to work he gets thumbs
so it comes home and he dumps on my
mother right of course right then the
bump on us so we gotta dump on us of
course right everybody's dump thumping
on everybody
even the humpins dump them most of the
time all right okay listen would you
just tell me what's wrong okay what is
it get in just tell me
Travolta received an Academy Award
nomination for his performance becoming
the fifth youngest nominee in the
category at the time and he went on to
reprise the character in 1983 Staying
Alive which the critics didn't love but
the fans spent their money on critics
say boasting a smart poignant story a
classic soundtrack and a star-making
performance for John Travolta Saturday
Night Fever ranks among the finest
dramas of the 1970s
beautiful come here to the edge and you
can look down look stop
[Music]
and ending 1977 on a high note was the
Mel Brooks mystery comedy high anxiety
with Brooks leading an ensemble cast
that included Cloris Leachman Madeline
Khan Harvey Corman and Dick Van Patten
this marked the first speaking lead role
for Brooks who also directed produced
and co-wrote the film he plays a doctor
who goes to work for a mental
institution and finds that the other
doctors may be crazier than the patients
and will do anything to cover up their
secrets high anxiety is a parody of
Alfred Hitchcock films like North by
Northwest vertigo and psycho with Brooks
working hard to emulate the look and
style of the iconic director's pictures
right down to hiring the same bird
Handler used for the birds
[Music]
oh
are you all right doc are you all right
I'm all right I'm all right profi I'm
all right I'm sorry sir
didn't know anyone was there
in the end the effort seemed worth it
with Hitchcock himself sending Brooks a
case of wine and a note about how much
he liked the film after a decent box
office Hall and High Praise from fans
and critics Brooks would go on to direct
the film's history of the World Part 1
and Spaceballs over the next decade all
part of what has become a legendary
career critics say uneven but hilarious
when it hits this spoof of Hitchcock
movies is a minor classic in the Mel
Brooks Canon okay wow 1977 was indeed
quite legendary and to think Darth Vader
only had 12 minutes of screen time in
Star Wars and here I am with a Darth
Vader Lego keychain 45 years later
anyway thanks for cruising back to the
70s with us I guess it's now time to go
watch Star Wars again and also
Spaceballs since I mentioned it earlier
see you next time